all right let's look at uh so the Durham
report this much anticipated Durham
report which was going to blow the roof
off of all of the wrongdoing that was
committed against Donald Trump when he
was being investigated uh total nothing
burger and we're going to look at this
through an interview this is actually
really interesting Donald Trump was
interviewed by fired Fox News host Dan
bongino yesterday and Trump told 20 30
lies about the content of the Durham
report this goes bad quick let's take a
listen I'm always excited to welcome
back to the show
a man who hopefully will be the next
president of the United States a good
friend to the show a good friend to me
uh personally president Donald J Trump
Mr President thanks for joining us right
hello Dan okay so it's often hello Dan
Trump in a bad mood bad mood Trump is
never good during interviews this has
been written about extensively when
Trump has that bad mood uh he is a
difficult difficult guy so it gets off
to a notably bad start they go right
into the Durham report and the lies
pouring out of Trump's mouth
Mr President we got the report yesterday
everything you said was correct this is
one of those hashtag Donald Trump was
right again moments is it uh sir you you
were framed you were framed they had no
evidence of any of this from there is no
reason to believe Trump was framed star
your thoughts on that
they thought they were going to lose and
we were indeed framed and it really
pertained more because they missed the
dates and amazingly uh the report was it
picked up until just after the election
even remember I think it was BuzzFeed
which is now essentially out of business
I understand which is a very good thing
for the uh for the country
it's great when media Outlets go out of
business per trump it was done sometime
after the campaign it actually affected
if you look at it and it really study it
it really affected 2020 much more
because we went through years of
nonsense with Russia Russia Russia I
didn't even know what they were talking
about people would come up to me sir you
know anything about Russia if you are
not understanding this word salad do not
adjust your television or mobile phone
or computer screen nobody can understand
what he's talking about here and after a
while I'd say what's going on with
Russia it was a frame up and these are
bad people this is Schiff and Clinton
and all these are bad people but it was
much more than the mark Elias you take a
look at what they did and this really
affected 2020 more than it affected
2016. it was meant for 2016 but they
couldn't get it off you know they they
had this fake dossier written by Steel
and who was offered millions in order to
try and get it confirmed did he stick
with it I'm going to go through all of
this with you in a moment couldn't get
it confirmed he couldn't get anybody to
confirm it because it was all fake it
was like you write a fiction book and uh
but this really affected the 2020.
another thing in the 2020 election which
was totally rigged by the way incredibly
how they didn't want to talk about that
then they didn't want to talk or Rick
but all you have to do is take a look at
the 51 intelligence agency that's raking
it take a look at truth to vote these
are great Patriots Catherine Engelbrecht
and these are great Patriots went around
for for a year took all of the tapes out
she sold all of these stuff the ballots
are boxes that took hundreds of
thousands of votes stuffing the ballot
boxes that took place and just you take
a look at just Twitter and the FBI Okay
so it goes on and on and on but let's
add a little bit of reality to this
Donald Trump and Dan bongino and others
would have you believe that the Durham
report exposed quite frankly that the
real crime was even investigating Donald
Trump and that Trump is Vindicated and
all these different things I don't know
how many of you have actually looked at
the Durham report the Durham report in
which they put all of their eggs in that
basket for years the Durham report found
no evidence of any deep State plot
against Donald Trump the way he claims
it does not accuse the FBI or doj of
acting out of political bias it doesn't
accuse the FBI or doj of acting out of
malice it doesn't allege any criminal
wrongdoing
by anybody that was involved in the
Mueller probe except for one low-level
lawyer who pled guilty to altering an
email in 2020 of no consequence big
picture to the investigation the report
did say some some aspects of how the FBI
handled the investigation like they
opened the investigation on a tip from
an Australian Diplomat they relied on
some uncorroborated information they
ignored uh elements of potentially
exculpatory evidence yeah there were
procedural errors that the Durham report
found it is not indicative of any
intentional misconduct political bias a
deep State plot a conspiracy against
Trump a frame up a frame job framing or
any of it and none of that affected the
validity of the outcome of the
investigation this is in the Durham
report
and Trump and bongino want you to
pretend it's something different the
report repeated some debunked conspiracy
theories that were pushed by Trump for
example it wrongly claimed the Steele
dossier triggered the investigation that
is not true that dossier didn't even get
to the FBI until September of 2016 that
was month three of the investigation
already so if you actually look at the
Durham report you find that all of the
stuff Trump is saying simply isn't true
let's listen to just a little bit more
of this interview we're skipping ahead a
little bit here I come
theater not prosecutor persecuted
because persecute is worse but Jack
Smith and he continues to go after Trump
with the phony boxes Hooks and if you
take the look at Biden Biden's got boxes
all over the place he had no right to
declassify I do and but you just take a
look Jack Smith this is a continuation
of the same hooks it's all the big hooks
they're all friends they're in there
they're embedded and it's really a
question it's rhinos and its Democrats
radical left Democrats I love the way
you suck your show with the radical left
you fight the radical level all right so
there has been no wrongdoing by the
special prosecutor that anybody has
actually been able to point to the idea
that any Republican that actually wants
to look into what happened is merely a
rhino a republican in name only is an
old tired grievance from Donald Trump
and the problem is you look at the post
if you look at this on on Troth Central
where Trump posted it people see this
drivel and then they post wow great show
great show Trump was right
etc etc etc they have fallen for it and
bongino is one of the henchmen that
pushes this nonsense on people look at
the Durham report and you'll see Trump
is lying one of our sponsors today is
relief band relief band is the number
one FDA cleared anti-nausea wristband
clinically proven to effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting relief band is a
type of therapy called transdermal
neuromodulation acue stimulation and in
really simple terms it's just a band you
wear on your wrist that sends a gentle
pulse to the part of your nervous system
that regulates nausea and there's been
growing research showing that relief ban
can help with nausea from motion
sickness from pregnancy and from all
sorts of other situations and a number
of studies suggest relief band can help
with nausea after surgery in conjunction
with medication many people use relief
band for nausea from anxiety or
migraines when you feel sick on a car or
plane or a boat it's simple it's safe
it's drug free and there are no side
effects relief band has an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau with
over one hundred thousand satisfied
customers online it's just a brand you
can trust you can go and read the
reviews let relief band help you make
nausea a thing of the past you'll get 20
off plus free shipping when you go to
reliefband.com and use the code Pacman
at checkout the link is in the
description